we're all set to go
set all right thank you everybody
um thank you for attending this
community input session regarding
redistricting
this session is being video end audio
reported to be subsequently placed
online and made publicly available
um and so you know this is not a typical
meeting of both committees because you
know there's not um not all members of
the committee are here before we get
started i think we have an announcement
for someone to make come on up
evening everybody and i hope everybody
had a good uh trip up i know we're kind
of out of the way up here in my hometown
of hayward but we like it here and we're
glad that you're here um just a couple
housekeeping issues i've been in touch
with maintenance about getting the
ventilation system going because it
automatically shuts down at 5 pm so
hopefully it'll be making you more
comfortable very shortly with respect to
ingress and egress of this building that
was
opened in february 1972 i know it's kind
of amazing here but the way that you
came in is the fastest way in the event
of a fire or something like that i know
that sounds kind of far-fetched but we i
just need to make sure that you are
aware of where the ingresses and
egresses of this building are in the
event
you know any other kind of emergency or
flames or something like that going
through this back door is going to lead
you down to another just push that go
forward clerk carlson our superior court
clerk has asked that nobody go into the
back hallway where the judge's offices
are etc but if you didn't need to do
that in the event of emergency that's
fine i will be out of the magnetometer
where everybody came in um if you folks
need me for anything um enjoy you stay
with us and any questions anybody has
about the safety of the building or
anything like that before i can get out
of your way here and let the important
stuff begin thank you thank you very
much deputy just so everybody knows
there was a little snag in communication
so the clerk and the sheriff's
department didn't know we were coming
so they did a last-minute adjustment to
their evening and i want to thank you
very much the sheriff that called it
home
was working late so they probably went
to my mother's house
[Music]
as this is a function of our general
court i'd like to begin by saying the
pledge of allegiance if you would join
me and stand
[Music]
thank you everyone this meeting is
occurring as you've just heard in the
grafton county courthouse
with the permission of the court
system and the county commissioners
please understand while we're in this
facility neither the courts of new
hampshire nor the county commissioners
of grafton have anything to do with this
public session
this public input session is for the
redistricting process
as it is underway in the general court
and staff of the general court work to
secure places to hold these sessions and
i'm grateful to the staff and the
organizations that control the use of
this facility to allow us to use them as
i stated this is a joint meeting of the
senate and the house redistricting
committee
we have members of both the house and
the senate here this is a joint meeting
and with that i would like to ask
senator gray who's
the chair of the senate redistricting to
welcome us to his senate meeting and
introduce the members
it didn't seem to like it when i turned
so i am senator james gray i am the
chair of the senate select committee on
redistricting i'm also the chair of the
election law committee
we do expect senator susie to arrive
shortly
um there's only three members on our
committee so uh but as
his with the legislature even one
representative or senator can take the
testimony and it will all be recorded so
that the people can see it uh no
cheering no booing
no signs
so
with all that i think we're all set to
go thank you that would be no cheering
okay
from the house my name is barbara
griffin i'm a representative from
goffstown and we have other house
members with us this evening so with
that if representative weber could we
start with you
[Music]
thank you madam chair i'm lindsay gipper
i sit on the house health human services
affairs committee and also on special
media redistricting i represent cheshire
one which is uh the river towns to the
south of walpole westminster
chesterfield and pittsfield and thank
thank you i'm representative lane i'm
from ward 2 in concord i'm also on the
i'm marjorie smith i represent durham
and madbury
in stratfor county uh in the house and i
serve on the judiciary committee in
addition to being on this committee the
special redistricting committee for the
house
good evening everybody uh representative
stratford county district 4 which is the
town of barrington
sit on obviously on this committee
also sit on finance committee a labor
committee and senior advisor in the
uh wayne mcdonald i was probably
representing londonderry which is
walkingham county district 5.
in addition to this committee i also sit
on the election line committee's vice
chairman
let's say representative matt wilhelm uh
manchester representing words one two
this is better great
um i serve on the state federal
relations
and veterans affairs committee
and uh in the practice of this committee
as well thank you
thank you and representative mcguire yes
thank you i'm carol mcguire representing
the towns of allenstown epstein
pittsfield in maryland county i'm the
chair of the house of dna committees
thank you everybody
um just so everyone is aware information
on the redistricting process for the
house of representatives can be found on
the general court website
once you're there select the house of
representatives and select the standing
committees of the house committees this
is the process you will get to any
committee
where you can review any bill that the
general court might be
considering
um this standing committee would be go
to would be the special committee on
redistricting the senate also has a page
and on those pages you will find a link
the house page will allow you to email
all committee members and has a link for
the committee website that page has
additional information on it for the
special committee and on redistricting
one of the things you will find on that
page is a link for meeting minutes and
recordings that's where the video for
tonight will be and it's usually there
the next day pretty promptly i'm not
quite sure what time but i expect it up
there in the morning
um we are here for redistricting and
redistricting is a process that occurs
throughout the country every 10 years
after the federal census is completed
that population data is used to create
districts for representation at all
levels of government
here in new hampshire our constitution
says the responsibility for the creation
of those districts is that of the
legislature
the districts to be redrawn in new
hampshire will be the congressional
executive council state senate and state
representative there is also
redistricting for county commissioner
districts and delegates to the state
party convention
there were handouts outside the door for
you with some information in regards to
representative numbers for counties and
information on grafton in crafting
county in particular
um
and for for
the house side it would be helpful for
us for public to comment on things
particular to you here in grafton county
but of course you can make comments on
any districts that you desire we are
doing this event in every county
um some of you have already done so
there's a blue sign up sheet outside the
room to sign up to talk we'll go to that
we're going to leave the other one out
there
and because it's important for everybody
to be recorded we're going to ask that
you come up here to be recorded because
this sound system actually
is the best
um that we've had so far so
um there was one other thing i was going
to announce but i can't remember what it
is so we're going to begin um as soon as
i get to the blue sheet with some with
public input oh i did what i did want to
add was in regards to the website there
is also a link to upload maps
and comments and someone has already
done that
promptly after i think our meeting last
week so that was really helpful so you
can look at those just as the committee
members can
it is something that you can avail
yourself of to submit information to us
and to see what information we have
received so thank you for indulging me
the first person we have that has signed
up to speak with is
[Music]
good evening and thank you madam chair
mr chair
members of the house and senate special
registration committees
my name is paul phillips i'm a resident
and voter in plymouth
and i'm also a small business owner in
middleton
welcome to grafton county
it's good to see you all here and i hope
you'll be back soon
in particular i hope you'll you won't
let this listening session be the last
opportunity to hear from the voters of
grafton county
about redistricting
once you have drawn a set of proposed
district maps
for consideration by the general court
i would like an opportunity
as with many other voters here in
grafton county and around the state to
offer comments
on those maps before state legislators
take any votes on them it's one thing to
talk about redistricting in the abstract
as we're doing
here tonight but it's quite another to
be able to offer comments and
perspectives on specific maps
that you have drawn
all voters need to have an opportunity
to comment on those maps in addition to
the opportunity you're providing here
tonight
i also want to urge
speaker packard and the members of these
special committees to open up these
listening sessions
in all your public sessions to a remote
auction
for those who cannot attend in person
the coveted pandemic is far from over
and many voters are justifiably
reluctant to attend a public indoor
gathering like this one
we need virtual sessions in which voters
can participate online
additional access and transparency can
only increase the legitimacy
of a process
that many voters already find murky and
confusing
the districts you are drawing are not
your districts
they're our districts
and you do yourselves in the entire
process of the service if you do not
take every available opportunity
including through remote participation
to hear from the voters whose right to
fair representation is the key to your
work
the 2011 redistricting process created
some obvious partisan districts
that have not served the voters of
grafton county very well
there are many examples i could point to
but for tonight i'll limit my discussion
to just three examples
the first example is the congressional
districts
the 2011-11 redistricting map
made an overtly political change
the map
drawers wanted to help the re-election
chances of the then incumbent
uh member in cd2
and so they decided to swap
one cd2 town campton
we all know how that turned out
politically
but in any event hampton is now the only
grafton county town in cd1
and center harbor is the only belknap
comedy town in cd2
you know better than i what you have in
mind for the congressional districts but
i would encourage you at the very least
to return camden and center harbor to
congressional districts that reflect
their geographic social and economic
my second example is the state senate
districts the 2011 map left grafton
county spread across four
senate districts
the northern towns are in sd1
the towns around the plymouth area are
in sd2
[Music]
the towns around hanover and lebanon are
in sd5
and then there's waterville valley
which is the only grafton county
community in sd3
i won't speculate about whether
incumbency protection or other political
factors drove that decision
but i would simply encourage you to find
a way to return waterville valley
to a state senate district with other
my third example is the floaterial
districts i certainly understand the
history of ontario districts
and i recognize the flexibility they add
to your options as map makers trying to
allocate 400 state representatives
across
all of new hampshire's communities of
interest
but i for one am not a fan of ontario
districts at least as they affect me and
my neighbors here in grafton town
yes they make sense in areas of high
population down south because they allow
you to keep
representative districts relatively
small
but up here in grafton county the
floaterial districts have the opposite
effect
the floaterial districts are large and
spread out
one example is wrapped in district 17
which covers six towns
in an hour long drive from ashland on
the shore of little swan lake
to enfield on the shore of mestoma lake
the incumbent state representative does
a terrific job
and is the hardest working elected
official i know
but grafton 17 is just too big
and spread out to reflect new
hampshire's
model of a state representative district
that is small and close to the voters
i would urge you when you're laying out
for ontario districts which i assume you
will do to find a way to keep them as
finally i just want to note for the
record that the 2020 census
shows that new hampshire's population of
color
the proportion is even higher among
younger granite staters
you have a constitutional duty not to
ignore the demographic shifts
in our state but to do your best to
create
districts that will allow voters to
elect a truly representative group
of public officials the demographic
ships in new hampshire as well as in the
united states generally are expected to
continue
and accelerate
over the next 10 years
as voters we are watching your work
carefully to see
how well you acknowledge and respect
new hampshire's changing population
i thank you for your time
and your hard work
and i look forward to talking to you
again
after your proposed learn preliminary
maps
for public review and comment thank you
thank you then chair of the members of
the committee it's my honor to be with
you this evening um i'm susan duncan i'm
from bristol new hampshire which is when
um
i wanted to share some of my
observations of having had the honor of
working 22 years in the new hampshire
state senate as a non-partisan employee
i came to this job having helped ned
with his senate district campaign
at that time um and i when i was hired
someone quit one day
and carol fletcher came to me and said
susan do you want a doctor's hey
and so i took it and stayed 22 years and
loved it and i was very blessed to be
here
but you have a lot of observations when
you sit there and you listen to
committee hearings and you watch people
work one of the things that i will note
is the thing that i have seen over and
over in my experience
not a one of you is north vega
your world's revolve around the
populated area of the state whereas i
our worlds are very small
i used to say to senator pig natalie i
said senator you can go to the mall
and see more constituents than that can
drive across half the district and find
we have to go 15 places
to do that
and it's not equal so one of the things
that i would request is as you look at
the district thing
the areas up here are huge
they are big and it takes a long time to
get from point a to point b
and do the job that many of you are
blessed enough to do in a visit at the
mall or going to the pizza place and
seeing 35 constituents
so that that's that's one point that
that i really would ask you to think
about that that we're not created equal
medium colleagues the twitty the dnc the
do-nothing zone because you had to fight
like the dickens to get anything to
happen exit of north events of 20.
and why because if the if the refs
and the senators from nashua and
manchester stood together
the whole rest of the senate could vote
they couldn't pass something
it's not
equal
and those of us in the north country
would like to be equal
you look at district one i don't know
how in god's green earth anybody runs a
campaign in senate district one
i thought ned's 32 towns
and it takes a lot of work and we should
thank these people that for the same
hundred dollars they're willing to do
the same job but it is a huge
disadvantage
but thank god we have good people who
want to work who want to serve and want
to come
and that's the main thing is just please
look at the district
and think about
we are not equal in the north country
and we would very much like to be equal
we'd love to be part of the committee
that makes these decisions and weighs in
um a one advanced town you can't get to
from one one of those towns to the other
without leaving the county
you don't know these things unless you
live up north
so
that's my major pitch tonight and i
thank you very much for listening and
next
madam chair and members of the committee
for the record
my name is gail kinney and i am a
resident of canaan um
i'm also a pastor with the united church
of christ denomination and so
i see this matter of redistricting
not just from the lens of a long time
resident
of a town that has been denied of its
constitutionally required representation
but i also see this matter through a
basic moral lens
and so starting with the moral lens um i
would implore this committee
to be transparent in what you do
because the reality is that democracy
dies in darkness
um
also to give voters a fair notice for
your meetings so people can plan and can
try to get here physically
um
as much as as possible and also um
i really implore you again as a matter
of basic morality to
really make this process as transparent
and as as fair as possible which means
giving people a say once there are maps
that you have put forth
um so that there's an opportunity to
react to something specific again just
as uh as opposed to providing you with
general information before you've made
your decisions um and finally as a
matter of basic morality
access to these sessions is really
important and i know that this committee
has not made the decision directly
to not allow remote access
but both for
reasons of transportation and reasons of
basic health and safety again i would
employ you to do what you possibly can
to ensure that as you move forward both
in this current process and that after
maps are developed that
there is an opportunity for access
beyond just people having to be here in
person
so now the specifics of being a resident
of canaan so i know the kanan select
board has has written to you
and uh so i urge you all to uh to take
that letter and to to consider it really
carefully um i would say that i think
that the select board was very polite
you know
in in its own communication but
i want to go back i think that their
basic point was that
legally constitutionally our town my
town is required to have a dis uh its
own representative district which we
have been robbed of for the past uh
decades so
i know that that someone else is going
to speak with specifics about kanan so i
won't get into all of the details but i
want to go back specifically to the
constitution
so back in 2011 when the last
redistricting process was done i watched
it very closely as closely as i could
however because it was done very quickly
and behind closed doors
and even though
even though in 2011
there was a constitutional requirement
in this state that towns such as mine
have its own district
i i
regret to say and i think that some of
you are already aware of this that in
that last redistricting process
in essence um
what they um
what the operative stance was is the
constitution be damned
and i don't believe this particular
committee
um i i certainly hope that you don't
have sort of the same
um
the same way of thinking that constant
that the new hampshire constitution
means
well you can do it if you want to but
you don't really have to
so i want to just read again and i know
you're all familiar with this but
i want to just emphasize
so on november 7
2006 the citizens of this state voted
um to make a change in part two article
11 of the new hampshire constitution so
that
on the end and in the constitutional
document itself it explains
that this amendment was made in 2006 to
enable towns with sufficient population
to have their own representative
district
and so the language of the constitution
reads
when the population of any town or ward
according to the last federal census
is within a reasonable deviation from
the ideal population for one or more
representative seats
the town or ward
shall have
shall
shall have its own district of one or
more representative seats
so my question to you as you go forth
my understanding is that there are at
least 60 towns
in the state of new hampshire i think a
little more than 60 that were robbed in
of the opportunity to have their own
representative districts even though the
constitution says shall
and so
i would ask you if you haven't already
as you started the process if you
haven't taken the constitutional mandate
and layered it
on top of the map and said okay
where are we not now following the
constitution and how do we cure that
with the max that we are drawing going
forward
if the constitutional requirement is not
a starting point for this committee then
i have a question why not
and i would ask the committee to explain
to the people of new hampshire
for whom the constitution
is a sacred document
why is that not taking place and why
isn't this all being cured so again i
implore you
cure the constitutional deficiency going
forward and i thank you for the work
i believe that redistrict redistricting
should be completed in as non-partisan a
manner as possible
perhaps it's naive for me to hope in
this polarized era
this can be done
but rather than one party putting its
thumb on the scale to tilt districts in
their favor
why can't there be an even-handed
attempt of fairness
why not allow all our voices to be heard
as a black woman i'm especially
concerned about gerrymandering that
diminishes the voices of people of color
rather than suppression why not
elevation why not uphold the spirit of
the voting rights act and promote free
and fair access to the polls
i also ask that this committee schedule
hearings after the maps are drawn
so that the public can weigh in on the
redistricting work
that has been proposed thank you
representative
thank you family members and uh thank
you for the job that you're doing and i
just want to start by saying i
appreciate the fact that the job that
you have to do is not a decent job
i'm sure redistricting is very good
uh i just have a couple of comments
today it won't be long as you see i
so
but
uh
the
the these
first of all i i i represent uh district
nine uh graphene county district nine
it's five towns
it's ashland bristol bridgewater
alexandria
and brad
and
first of all just to say i live in
bristol
uh love bruce i have lived there for
47 years now
and
grew up in alexandria so the district is
uh is dear to me
and bristle is dear to me and bristol
very much would like to have its own
representative as you could if you look
at the numbers we have 3 400 somehow
people there were within a reasonable
deviation of the ideal number and
bristol would very much like to have its
own representative right now we have two
representatives in the large district
and a floatario representative
the
district when i look at the districts it
looks like they were created by a
machine
um
it looks like somebody
had a computer program that just said
want these
go down from the top of the county and
go down the county
and lump these towns together so you
come out with an ideal number
and it looks like my district
is five towns at the bottom of the
county
who really don't have much of a common
interest three of them do because
they're in the newfound district the
newfound area school district so bristol
and alexandria and bridgewater they have
a common interest
but then there's ash
there's only one road
basically
to get from bridgewater to
ash one road unless you go out into
belmont county you look to ireland
and then on the other side there's rap
there's gravitonography
and that goes to the and ashland goes to
the plymouth school district the penny
baker school district
on the other side is
grafton goes to the mascara school
district
when i get called to go to school
meetings
there's you have to drive 40 miles from
one
high school to the other you might just
this is this is a house district
it just doesn't make any sense
it
and it looks to me and i and i look
through the districts and
and virtually it seems like almost every
district in in the county is like that
for some reason
i just don't get it it seems to me that
if i were to start doing this
redistricting rather than plugging
numbers into a computer what i would do
is start looking at the school districts
because those are the commonalities of
i look at the newfound school district
and say hey there's
there's there's uh five towns in grafton
county that go there you know there's
the pemmie baker that's it
the tummy baker that's the mascoma all
of these school districts together would
make a whole lot more sense because you
have the commonalities of interest
you know
ashland being
on
one side of the merrimack river and
grafton focusing in on the connecticut
river communities have absolutely
nothing to do with each other
they certainly in terms of paying taxes
all have the same interest but
uh and they have very different
interests
and so my suggestion is that you look at
particularly at the school districts and
trying to put the school districts
together and have some commonality of
interest and put a human touch in the
way you design the district
the only other comment this is sort of
on the senate side having
served
i served four terms as a senator here in
largely grafton county
but
uh if you and i think the point was well
taken about waterloo about
being outside the county makes for
whatever reason it just
maybe it was just
a number but it should be in grafton
county and it should be within the
grafton county senate district as best
as it can be which it used to be and i
understand that
district one is probably going to have
to move down because they have reduced
population and further into graph and
county as it did in the last
redistricting
but the one thing i'd say is for senate
district 2 which is the senate district
that serves this particular area
it would be best if you didn't right now
it's three counties
it would be best if when you're redoing
those senate districts that you
with senate district two you just did
two counties and not
to go into three separate counties
as a senator it makes more sense to have
to do with two county governments than
it does three or four
so
those are those are
generally my
my suggestions
again i know it's a difficult job
i don't think
i just
re echo what everybody else has said is
that's
just be fair and do as much as you can
to put a human touch on it
so
thank you
thank you for the opportunity to speak
this evening
my name is mike sampson i'm the town
uh i've been
in town government and
state and local
politics for
about 55 years
and i go back long enough so i remember
the time
when people gathered in communities
in the state government
primarily for problem solving
it was not partisan
i feel comfortable saying that i
remember it well
i had the opportunity to experience it
firsthand
and i appreciate it more and more every
day
that willingness to gather together to
make things happen
i work in canaan my border selectmen i
sent you a letter i'm the
senator of my board chairman
in terms of politics my entire two of my
board members are republicans one's a
democrat
i'm a democrat
as the politics
all of us live in the town of canada
and we have a little bit under 3 900
residents citizens in kenya
so we met we met the criteria back in
for a single
district
we meet the criteria still
we know the constitution says we racist
as a matter of fact i raised this issue
for the last committees that worked to
design districts back in 2011.
i've been around kenya for a few years
and
that time we also asked that would be
considered that we have at least one
so today i'm here before you
we have two representatives
in 11 and
16.
and uh i think it's 16. hopefully i got
there right
and i suspect some of you may have
driven up through wentworth
seen it some of you probably did not
drive up through canada but it's out
there somewhere
and
the key thing about it is if i think of
my own town where i have to solve a
whole bunch of problems every single
year
i have to solve water problems i have to
solve super problems i have to do a
private school so i have to deal with
public schools
i have to deal with a
education funding formula that cripples
our tax
rate in canada
i think we're like the 15th highest in
the state of new hampshire
at the view of those problems
i have to deal with a community that
doesn't want zoning it also doesn't want
the problems
when there is no zone
i have to deal with a
huge number of diverse
problems in
canaan i have a health center so so does
the wentworth area
but
and there is a private school somewhere
nearby wentworth but we have one in the
community
we have
thousands of acres
of
conserved land and protected land that
doesn't help our taxes
those are all issues that we have in
cape
i just had to make a huge change a
million dollar 1.2 million dollar change
in our water system
you know how much grant money i've got
in the state of new hampshire for that
project
zero
i know you all have private water and
sewer projects you're familiar with them
you know what the funding systems are
i've got zero so i just wanted forty
percent
of my water and sewer rates
to cover the cost of necessary repairs
those are issues in cadence
and with all due respect to our
representatives in wentworth
and i will say that i have gotten
cooperation
both from the senate and from the house
on issues that have come up before us
but in terms of having the day-to-day
voice
in the legislature so there could be
conversation
dialogue
so i'm beseeching you
i think that there's some other language
that may have been a little more harsh
in the letter
but as a person that has to deal with
those issues
i'm beseeching you
to honor the constitutional requirement
and give us a voice
give us a voice please give us a voice
so we can be part of the dialogue
that'll solve problems
so all i'm asking for is a voice
a lot of representatives
i think somebody mentioned that there's
60 little communities to fit this
criteria
please consider
honoring the constitution of this state
and give us when it says shall that's
what it's supposed to be it's supposed
to happen
please give us a seat if you still want
to have us part of an eighth
town
legislative district okay
at least we got one voice
that we would have
that could represent the people that
can't afford their water and sewer bills
can't afford the education tax
that have other problems that are
inherent in being in the community our
size with the diversity we have
because the alternative here
is not you know we really want to
support problem solving
not partisan politics
not partisanship
so what do we have to do to guarantee a
voice when we go to elections next year
we're going to have to vote for anybody
name the party
as long as they're from canaan now at
least give us a candid voice
so let's try to be a little bit more
reasonable where we can actually pick
the most qualified candidate in canaan
to represent us
in the legislature for problems up
give us a voice please
the constitution says
i know your job is difficult i did it in
another state in vermont i know how
difficult it is in every state and i
know that people have looked for
solutions forever
the one advantage you have
it's better than having 150 seats or 120
seats in terms of being able to
represent communities
so that's it it's that's the end of the
appeal we do i think all of you got a
copy of our letter
now we mean it it isn't just some
letter that somebody somebody did ask
it's all right we had it come from the
community
but at least two of the board members
were on the board
in 2011 when this issue came up
both of them strong republicans and both
of them agreed at that point so what
listen to us please and if you can do
anything to address this it would be
helpful it would be it'd be terrible to
campaign based purely on we need to have
a voice from camden's elected king
so that's all i have thank you very much
for the opportunity to speak
thank you madam chair members of the
committee
um
there's a nice balance of representation
[Music]
okay
there's a nice balance of representation
the way the north country above the
north notch districts
are laid out right now
living in the north country especially
we know the importance of networking and
collaborating to get things done
so that is what north country reps do
they work together
to address north country issues
for our constituents
and to me
that is one of our greatest strengths
chair many members um darla bruno from
lebanon
just a voter i'm not as eloquent as some
of these other folks that have spoken
already but
i just want to say that uh
i think we voters are kind of really
tired of the partisanship
and gerrymandering
we want fairly drawn districts that are
neutral not favoring one side or the
other
and
logically drawn as well
i mean and we want transparency we want
to know if you're using software we want
to know what the algorithm is that
decided what these districts are going
to be
i hope we could avoid that route if
possible
as we've heard from others i think a
little more
thinking needs to go into it than just
allowing software to
draw the districts
um
and also i think you know we need to
hear the voices of the people who can't
physically come to these meetings
the people who are sick or disabled or
too elderly to come
their voice counts too they still vote
and they have a right to be heard both
before
and after
the maps have been drawn
so please consider that and our
democracy is hanging by a thread right
now
and i hope that you folks will be the
people that bring it back from the brink
rather than the ones that help push it
over the edge
thank you for those comments
[Music]
some of you
came from a really long distance to be
uh
i come from canada
i served in the new hampshire house for
four terms
and so i'm a little bit
uh
acquainted with the redistricting
process i was there during the 2011
redistricting
i'm also
somewhat acquainted with the
constitution
and besides the part of the constitution
that says
a town like kenya should have its own
representative the constitution also
said that
uh districts
this is in
part two article nine says districts
shall be elected and founded on
principles of equality
and representative therein shall be as
i've heard committee members say that 90
of the redistricting
decisions
are based on population
and it's only 10 percent that can deal
with other banks
i think that we have to change that
uh because
people population does i mean equal
towns does not mean
equal population is not equal quality
accounts equality includes as much as
possible the same regional planning
area
the same school district certainly
the same medical and recreational
resources the same geographical area
area
and this district
disregards these principles of equality
the select pen would be ignoring our new
venture constitution
i'll
repeat some of what people have said
before about the results of the
redistricting in 2011 11 for
kane
canaan
district
uh
sau 62
but the district goes into an
other school district all of the uh
all of the townspeople of the district
are not in the same school district
canaan is in the upper valley son of the
regional planning area
the network is now
kanan is in the
mascoma valley watershed
you have to go over to the
mountain to the baker river watershed in
order to
uh get to the other end of our districts
canaan's churches don't attract people
from wentworth and wentworth's church
doesn't attract people from canaan
canyon residents use skin community
healthcare and dr hitchcock for medical
needs
wentworth residents don't come over the
hill to us they go towards women
travelers from canaan to wentworth the
northern part of the space station
traveled through two towns
rotten and rumbly in order to get from
katie to wentworth the third town in its
history
so when worth does not share schools
does not share regional bank does not
share labor and commercial areas medical
or recreational resources or a
and so i say that the district
violates article
that article from part two of our
constitution
the mathematical formula which has been
used for determining plateau districts
theoretically it's each representative
equal numbers of voters but practically
it clearly doesn't do that
the representative elected and drafted
district 9 my base district has to win
votes and serve 4
978 residents
the representative from grafton from
district 16
in the exploitarial district which
extends the strength from payment to
include dorchester wentworth
orange
romney ellsworth
and
thornton
here across the middle of the state
has to campaign and win votes from an
area with 10
123 residents this is not giving the two
representatives
the same number of voters to represent
it is not a fair to the either to the
people of those towns or to the
representative that
represents such a diverse group
but there's a way that we can solve the
problem
with its population 3794
deserves its own district as required in
part to article 11.
enfield with a population about 4 400
also
should continue to have its own district
if we create a third district
which includes the excess population for
canaan and enfield
and the towns of grafton dorchester and
orange
which
share the same
community the same school district and
work together very well
uh
the population of those combined towns
if you think of three districts from
enfield kenya and overlying district
including all five towns it is within
3.8
of the target population
and so i hope that you will look very
carefully and consider that as an
alternative
i will
a taste
if i may distribute it which
uh
tries to describe that so thank you very
much for being here and for listening to
me i
do want you to work hard
thank you very much for that
the next sign up that i see here from
thank
you i'm catherine moore holland
and i was a representative or a plateau
district
i think
one of the things that you should
consider more
specifically than anything is to
eliminate any ontario district at all
i felt it was very hard to represent my
community
particularly and this has been
emphasized already the school districts
are absolutely crucial to the unity of
the special
district
and
the only way we can work together is
of interest
which overrides partisanship and deals
with the good of the community and the
communities being able to work together
and i think that's true of
throughout the state of junction and
thank you for listening
general
i've sort of combined a couple of things
my husband's already talked about the
representation and came in in the past
i'm going to touch on it again
this should be that we had um
in 2001 and again it was a republican
controlled
discernment process gave us a very nice
description for the five masculine towns
and it was a it was shaped about like
this where the five towns were all
contiguous
um
and we had representatives from the
district and if we did what chuck has
suggested and had one rep for for
enfield one for kenyan and one with the
excess combined with the other the other
three smaller towns
um would basically be revisiting what we
had um in 2001 which worked very well
the people in the massacre committee
has come to district um we see each
other if we go to the school school
board meetings um
in the school
we also see each other and each we go to
each other's um
uh home days we go to school we go to
the same churches
we go to the same shops we go heard the
same restaurants we see each other so
many in so many ways the representatives
um knew people
um and people knew who the
representatives were
and now we don't we have people who are
way off in the town that you can't get
there from here without leaving
um
without leaving the area because the
alveolar actually goes between them is
closed in the winter um
and i wanted to say also is that um
the representation
i i thought at one point or maybe the
other statement should have been more
fair for the representatives than it is
for those being represented
but it doesn't work very well either way
for instance enfield which is a town of
4 400
has two representatives one uh
on its own and one in this ontario
district was grafted into the town of
about thirteen hundred thousand third
the size of enfield is three
representatives
um that's in three words that challenge
one through the size of the other
has
one and a half you know has 50 percent
more representation
um
because of the weight of the districts
were
um that also
um
someone who represents
enfield has
um
four thousand four hundred constituents
but there's no representations
and that photographer told me that's one
representative was 14 000 constituents
so it's not fair to anybody
coming and going it's not fair to the
people who need a presentation it's not
fair for people who are trying to
represent the people uh who elect them
so
please consider very carefully
uh how you're building communities and
and how full the representation is to
each person and how reasonable the job
is that you're assigned to each of the
representatives
thank you
david andrews has signed up david did
you have some maps did you want to go at
good evening dave andrews uh
i just wanted to talk a little bit about
uh graphic county in particular uh it's
been mentioned before
but for the uh congressional districts
campaign is kind of an outlier in that
it's in district one it's the only town
in grafton county in district one it's
the only
town it is uh sau in district one it's
the only town in its public health
region in district one it's really um
should be in district two with the rest
of grafton county
and then i wanted to talk a little bit
about the
state house districts
the
difficult part
of districting
in new hampshire is the calculation of
the floaterials
and
i know i've done a lot of mapping
and uh
i spent hours
trying to come up with maps for the
house districts in grafton county and
the absolute best i could do with the
current methodology
was still having three towns not get
their own representatives that should um
i was unable to give i believe it was
plymouth infield and kanan their own
representative using the current
methodology
but with the alternative component
method that i
developed
it would allow for all of the towns that
are eligible for their own districts to
have their own districts and thus their
representatives
so i would just ask that you
consider the alternative component
method again as a methodology for
calculating flow tarials
i would be happy to answer any and all
questions uh pertaining to that
methodology and um
yeah
thank you for your time
thank you for
coming mr andrews for those of you who
don't know has been in all of our public
campus sessions so
if i seem familiar to
systematically
mask off
glasses on
mic down good evening
and thank you for this opportunity i'm a
late comer this evening my name is sue
prentice i'm from lebanon new hampshire
and i'm also the state senator for
district five
which includes lyme hanover canaan
enfield
lebanon cornish plainfield
claremont and charlestown
i just want to speak briefly tonight on
a few points i was struck as i came into
this this is my first time speaking
before distributing committee
at dirk for pro in this process
that we are all here tonight you are all
here because
we're here for the people we're here for
the greatest staters
and your job and ultimately
our job is to make sure that maps are
drawn that provide fair and equal
representation
i think
i rise and shine every day remembering
that our job is for the grand people
that we serve here in the granite state
i want to make a few quick points just
about the process the before and the
after so speaking to
fairness
and to transparency
public hearings so we're having those
obviously because we're here tonight and
i know of others
but including and others have spoken
about this
in this day and age of a worldwide
pandemic it's unprecedented
that well number one a worldwide
pandemic like this is unprecedented in
our time but not having access for
people who are
immunocompromised have other health
issues as well as the inability to
travel i find that unfortunate and would
hope it could be reconsidered i am
pleased that there is um
there is streaming live streaming taking
place i think that that is definitely a
step in the right direction but i think
we need to open that door
websites that or a common location where
you could go and not only see the dates
but find information now when i googled
might be the platform that i'm using but
when i googled new hampshire
redistricting um gerrymandering
regis really focused on redistricting in
new hampshire
i finally found my way to the general
court website where i found
i could look for or locate two areas
that i could click on to learn about the
senate side and the house side but i
think elevating the prominence of that
and i could be missing something i think
is also
equally as important for for public
access
routine public communication again
through websites and these sex
appearance
and making sure that
at the end of the day the rationale that
is used is made clear and clearly
described to the members of the public
again speaking in the before and then
the after we're here
now talking about the process
but more importantly and i've heard
others speak to this tonight will be the
opportunity that we should have to
respond to the maps once they are drawn
and
i like you and i'm sure many of you in
this room if not all look forward to
that opportunity as well um i'd like to
speak to the maps themselves and what i
consider what they should look like and
just thinking about inclusive that maps
should be inclusive with engagement
opportunities so we're talking about
common areas
common problems that need common
solutions and so how do we do this
one we think about the landscape there
are
rural and urban areas suburban areas
micropolitans throughout this district
as well as throughout the state they
need to be considered
the population numbers and the growing
diversity in our population so diverse
and a number of special times tonight
serving multiple county governments
multiple school boards
those should be considered as well and
social compacts i believe are equally as
important i was reflecting as it was
gene townsend was talking about the
canaan farmers market is one of the most
popular places
in canaan to be on a sunday morning and
neighbors know neighbors elected
officials no elected officials
and that's how they talk about the
common problems
and the common solutions that they're
going to work on together and i think
that we need to take that take that into
consideration
and preserve that
and the last thing i'm going to say is
i'm going to join the voices without um
i'm going to join the voices they're
advocating for and
representative for the town of canaan
we've heard from the town administrator
mike sampson we've heard from gail kitty
we've heard from chuck townsend and
we've heard from gene townsend um not
just about the constitutional
responsibility that we have but the
importance this decision
has been looming for years and it's it's
well known and i think the town
administrator was one of the speakers
who could talk about the common problems
of the common solutions that aren't
as easily solved with the distance
provided
between how they are represented now and
look at the numbers of look at their
population numbers and their diversity
so i'm joining without repeating what's
been said um the chorus advocating for
kanan to have their own representative
again i know many of you have traveled
far see one of my colleagues who came up
here all the way from rochester um and
uh i appreciate the opportunity to speak
with you tonight and thank you for the
work that you were doing
is there anyone else here who would like
hi thank you for taking my testimony my
name is mary heckon phillips and i'm a
hanover resident
i'm also a representative from grafton
county district 12 serving hanover
online
i am a practicing attorney out of
concord
and i hold a master's degree in
political science so
that kind of gives you a color of the
background of my comments
first i'd like to thank all the folks
who've been here tonight giving
testimony
and participating in this process it's a
great
you know practicing democracy to hear
from people and to influence our process
and i'm just so thankful that so many
i'd also like to thank the committee
this is obviously a difficult job
can often be thanked thank less so i
appreciate
you know your public service to our
community and our state and for
endeavoring in this difficult task
it is noble work and we do appreciate it
thank you
um i do have a few concerns tonight that
i'd like to bring to the committee's
attention specifically the article 1
section 2 requires the apportionment of
state representatives of the states
that must be carried out every 10 years
which we know is the census which
obviously is now complete and why we're
here
and you are in the thick of redrawing
these maps
my concerns are fivefold
one
i do represent hanover and lime as
mentioned before
and i'd like to bring to your attention
that hannover warrant article number 27
was passed at our town meeting in 2021
this year
asking and resolving this process for
redistricting should be a fair and
effective representation of new
hampshire voters and that an independent
redistricting commission should draw
these maps in a way that does not rely
on partisan data like election results
party registration
or favor political parties or candidates
just like to reiterate that
i am concerned about a fair and
transparent process for redistricting
before and after the maps are drawn
let's talk about what that would look
like before proper notice should be
given at least 10 days prior to hearing
for the other jurisdictions that you'll
be seeing
in the next few weeks
we need these 10 days because people
need time to arrange child care elder
care
work arrangements etc
this time is crucial and i am important
to include it in your future meetings
access
public hearing hearings should be
accessible to those who cannot attend in
person
given obviously the pandemic that we're
all experiencing but also other health
concerns and ability concerns child care
or elder care that i just spoke about
and also work arrangements
remote av access
like zoom for instance
should be made available for these
hearings so that all regardless of
status or situation can participate by
providing testimony by hearing the
comments in the room and by watching
i implore you before these maps are
drawn to collect these facts these
concerns and this testimony
to compile this record in such a way
prior to drawing the maps but also to
incorporate those exact findings into
your map drawing process
a fair and transparent
process will also include
this work after the maps are drawn
um first notice is an important issue
unlike the last redistricting effort
i'd like your committee to give
more than 24 hours notice when those
maps are redrawn for public review and
comment and to make those redrawn maps
available publicly as soon as possible
please don't delay a secretary's process
will not benefit anyone
i'd also like you to issue a report
responding to the facts and the
testimony that you've heard
across the state and explain how you
chose to or not
to include that in your redrawing
efforts
a fair and transparent process should
also include
an important methodology review like
many other young professionals to move
to our area i represent a key
constituency of taxpayers who believe
that science facts logic and reason
should be driving our state's policy
making to solve problems just like this
redistricting that means i understand
partisanship will definitely play a role
but i'm imploring you
please avoid the dangerous abuses that
can be very enticing when re-drawing
lines
simply put there should be no packing
and no cracking
when large cities and towns are packed
together and small communities are
cracked apart it becomes very obvious
that these constituents are being robbed
of their real representation
a second concern tonight or sorry that's
the third concern tonight that i have
are constitutional considerations
like to remind you that daniel webster
once said the right to choose a
representative is every man's portion of
sovereign power
i may remember this being cited in
burling versus the speaker of house 2002
before our supreme court
also part 2 article 9
11 our new hampshire constitution
require
for about each
four hundred and forty four percent
there should result the single seat for
either a town or a multi municipal area
or floating material district
um in a way that
it shows each person's vote has equal
weight
our state law requires that state
legislative districts be contiguous and
maintain the boundaries of towns awards
or unincorporated places
these so-called material districts
should be among communities
something that's been raised several
times tonight
specifically i'd like to speak to the
executive council maps which should be
redrawn to more accurately reflect
common communities of interest and
reflect partisan balances within the
state
for example
the second district's partisan
gerrymandering is really quite egregious
and i implore you to fix it
a federal consideration
is that congressional districts should
and remain competitive districts
you can see through population shifts
through our census that not much has
changed for our congressional districts
any shifts that have arrived or that may
change in your maps should remain
largely the same in terms of the line
drive
you should reflect common school
districts public utilities and fire
departments
i'd also like to remind you that the new
hampshire supreme court in the burling
versus the speaker of the house case in
was a place where our granite state
justices hired a consultant and
determined a more equitable
apportionment under the court's plan as
it's identified in the case
i encourage this commission to use a
similar methodology to avoid
additional litigation as the outcome of
just redistributing the process
furthermore let the united states
supreme court
encourage um
be your guiding light excuse me
i encourage this commission to rely
heavily on reynolds versus sims from
1965 and established
in that case the principle for one
person one vote
for an aqua population requirement
beware as well that the equal protection
clause can provide grounds for any
future racial gerrymandering claims
originating in our metropolitan areas or
my fourth concern is about potential
litigation being a lawyer something i
know about something about it
first the cost of litigation
the center for public integrity in 2012
released grading reports for
transparency across the united states
and in 2010 new hampshire scored very
low
the process
was burdened here in our state because
it was hidden largely from the public
view
when the master released at the very
last minute it didn't help the process
as well
expensive litigation no doubt fouled uh
because of that untransparent
unauthentic process
and who flipped the bill our taxpayers
in december 2020 the national conference
of state legislatures published a work
entitled more redistricting transparency
thus litigation by rebecca greene
one of the conclusions is that when
there's an increased authentic
transparent process for redistricting
there's a statistically significant drop
in litigation rates
now
another conclusion was that the courts
tend to draw adverse inferences against
secretive redistricting processes
we can do better here in the future
let's aim for an a grade
let's have authentic transparency
throughout our process and avoid
expensive and expensive litigation for
our taxpayers
my last concern is the consequences of
gerrymandering
it hurts us because districts do not
reflect the accurate balance of
partisanship which further divides our
political parties one party
is given a majority in the state house
despite only having a minority of the
votes
and it's at the expense of the minority
party
politicians are picking their voters
voters
don't pick their elected officials in
this case
as miss massimilia has said earlier
tonight just regular voters want mutual
districts
heed their call
in 2018 the brennan center reported the
majority of americans oppose partisan
gerrymandering
and in 2019 the alg research opinion
polls showed that 70 of voters from all
parties
agree that skoda should place some
limits on gerrymandering
and 55 of all voters with partisan
affiliation have unfavorable views of
the practice
ask yourself
what does this mean politically over
time if you continue to draw these
partisan maps
what does it mean for your party what
another consequence of gerrymandering is
that our districts will not represent
the people itself
it will limit our voting rights will
hurt our children
and hurt people of color
it divides communities from their
natural commonalities and traffic flow
their geographic and natural landmarks
a political question for you
at a time when public confidence in
government is at an all-time low if you
create a pre-ordained outcome under new
hampshire gop leadership to deprive the
voters of any meaningful influence
in the next election ask yourself are
you prepared to own the decision
to rob those americans of their most
fundamental way to participate in our
democracy
ronald reagan said
that's all we're asking for to end the
undemocratic and un-american practice of
gerrymandering
the fact is gerrymandering has become a
national scandal
do not let new hampshire become the next
north carolina
the next ohio the next pennsylvania
national embarrassment
for this kind of redistricting extremely
partisan on top of the recent polarized
climate and concord
i'm trying to give you notice that a
religious generation gerrymandering
mapped
math excuse me is going to add one more
tip
marked the reasons why new hampshire
could be stripped of its first
elimination primary and for you
as an attorney and foreign constitution
i deeply believe
more than that i have a professional
duty and a moral obligation to support
laws
that are equitable inclusive
and just for all granite staters
i'm honored to serve the communities and
this community
and my conscience requires my advocacy
for a fair and independent registration
process
i encourage you to please take these
concerns
into consideration in your endeavors
moving forward
thank you for your time
thank you very much for coming in your
testimony i apologize i think that i
skipped over is there an inward purpose
here
i'm ingrid curtis from hanover
and i want to thank the committee for
their work
and also say
you have a tremendous opportunity right
now
in this redistricting to improve
the partisan
politics that we've gotten into
as a state
we have many many things that we care
about in common especially if
we are redistricted
better in a better way for the natural
communities to be united in their
representation
and i think
we're all unhappy
with what's happened with the increasing
partisanship in this country
and
this is a way
if you can be
transparent
people can know why the decisions were
made and have input on why the decisions
were made
and common sense is used
that we can
make a start towards making things
better and not do another step
of having
partisan redistricting
that harms us all and i assume that you
all care about new hampshire and the
interest in new hampshire
um
and that
we all know that that's the best way to
go
that in the long term
making decisions based on anything but
fairness
and equality are really harmful to the
country so i implore you to use your
opportunity to improve things in this
state
and not go down the road we've been
going
thank you
is there anybody else here with us
tonight that would like to speak in
regards to this process
i'm not seeing anybody i want to thank
you all for coming out
we appreciate your participation in this
and letting us know um and
i'm
happy to hear from kanan we we thought
we might based on them on the letter so
you know thank you for coming and
reinforcing where you are have a safe
trip home everybody
yes
thank you i was asked to ask
as a matter of
understanding for our committee members
if they're going to be votes taken
at our regular community meeting in
concord on thursday and so what they are
i'm not sure and i've been in
communication with
your ranking member in regards to that i
believe you received a copy of that
email and that would be the forum to
continue that discussion thank you
thank you good night everybody i think